- I'm shook.
(upbeat guitar music)
- We're here to tell my daughter
a secret that is probably
at this point 30 years old.
It's something that I think she'll find
surprising and out of character.
- I feel like my kids always pretty much
know everything anyways,
but this one secret has been
going on for quite a while.
- He does some strange
stuff, it can be anything.
- I mean, they know that I'm gay,
but they don't know what that
means in my life, really.
I've kind of kept them
sheltered from that.
- I don't know if that's true, but okay.
He has a video on YouTube
called I'm Gay Gay.
- I'm an open book with her.
- I still feel like there's
a lot that I haven't
heard about my dad, I'm gonna be honest.
- I don't know, I don't know.
- I really feel like
there's some wild stuff.
- No, I just need to tell him.
You know that I've been
going to karaoke, right?
- [Noah] You kinda stopped,
but I know that you--
- I did stop.
But like every Monday
I was going to karaoke.
- [Noah] Yeah.
- I'm a drag performer.
I have like a total drag persona.
I know you know that I'm gay and that
I dress up every once in a while.
- And what's the name?
- Herlinda.
- Herlinda?
- (laughter) Herlinda.
- I'm ready.
- You ready?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Being a doctor--
- Right.
- You know that I told you
I always wanted to do it
from the time I was a little kid.
- Yeah.
- As long as I could possibly remember.
- After the end of my second year,
I had been named chief
resident for the third year.
- Yeah!
- And I quit the program entirely.
- What?
- I quit.
I resigned.
I not only resigned from
being chief resident,
I resigned from medicine, I quit.
- Wait, are you kidding me?
- [Steven] I'm not kidding you.
- Woah!
This is mind blowing!
- And I had no idea what I was gonna do,
I literally just couldn't take it anymore.
- So then, so you quit, which is a word
that doesn't apply to him ever.
- Do you wanna see her?
- Sure.
Oh man.
You know, it's just not that surprising,
because he used to do
drag every Halloween.
- I just sat down and I
talked to mom about it,
and I said, "You know, this
just doesn't feel right.
"But even though I'm miserable
and this is horrible,
"it's just two more
years, I'm halfway done."
So when I came to them and said,
"Look, I've reconsidered
and I'm gonna come back,"
they were happy to have me back.
- This is like a huge
chunk of family story
that I've been missing.
He just does a lot of things right,
and I think my dad's
like the smartest person
and the most dedicated person,
so it's nice to know that
when he was around my age,
he did a really terrible,
made a really bad move.
And you know what the biggest life lesson
that my dad tells my
sister and I, don't quit.
- Are you good?
- I think I'm pretty good,
I've got a little bit of a following.
- Do I get to come now?
- Yeah, you need to come.
- I'll have to come see you do drag.
- I feel like this is
my second coming out.
But I appreciate that
you're not being judgmental.
- Well, you aren't the
prettiest girl I'd ever seen,
but you looked alright.
- It's gotten a lot better.
- Better than that?
- Rising from the dead,
as Taylor Swift says.
- [Steven] Is that what she says?
- Oh yes.
- Yes.
- Thoughts?
- Oh, there was another secret?
- Oh no, he likes Taylor Swift?
(laughter)
- No!
- I hate to tell you, but I'm a closet ...
I have a playlist.
I was gonna take mom to the show, yeah,
when she tours for this album.
- That's not a real thing.
- Yes!
- No!
- I just hope he's good at it,
'cause it's a little bit more
embarrassing if he's bad.
I need a good drag queen
dad, not a bad one.
- Does this make you look at me different?
- Yes.
Just like, out of the
two people sitting here,
who would you guess is the fan?
- Bigger Taylor Swift fan?
- It's good that it's out there,
but it feels a little strange.
It was nice having my own little life.
- Basically what he just said is
the reason he didn't tell me
is because he didn't want
me cramping his style.
- This was a good experience.
- Oh yeah?
- I have plenty to use against you now.
- Oh, okay.
- A lot of ammo.
- I am not embarrassed.
- Oh, I think there will
probably still be more secrets.
I think we can have our own lives.
- You gotta keep secrets sometimes.
(upbeat music)